the reason why I'm an Android developer
is because of the platform's massive
reach building for Android means that
you can build something here and it will
reach people all the way across the
world in fact the next billion people
coming online will interact with
Internet for the very first time using
only a mobile device there's so many
people who are consumers of technology
but I think it's so much more powerful
to be a creator of technology everyone
has unique experiences and strengths and
they can draw on that and use that to
identify problems in their community and
then use technology to solve that I
really feel like there's a big
opportunity to show people that they can
create something really amazing you can
imagine something that you think should
exist and you can actually go and build
it I can't think of anything more
powerful than that you can start your
journey to become an Android developer
today with your dad seeing google's
nanodegree